My entry into astronomy was purely by chance.
I never set out to be an astronomer, or even
a scientist, but when I was in college I had
an elective course to take, and astronomy
was one of the electives, and it looked like
fun.
So I said, "Okay, I'll take that course."
And I remember when I walked into the class,
there were only three other people in the
room.
Two of them were male graduate students, and
one of them was a senior, and me, a sophomore
girl.
And I remember going in to the professor and
saying, "I don't think that I belong in this
class."
He said, "No, no.
This is for you.
I want this class to be for sophomores, you
know.
Stay in the class."
And a few weeks went by, and I was really
struggling in college, and it was clear to
me I had to drop a course.
And I was either going to drop my astronomy
course or drop my history course.
I went in to the professor and I said, "I
really.
I think I need to drop your class because
I need to drop one class, and I don't have
any data yet for my project", and blah blah
blah."
He said, "Look.
Let's go out to our observatory tonight."
We had a little observatory.
"And see if you can get some data, and if
you do, then you could write your project.
It'll be fine."
And he said, in retrospect, thank goodness
it was clear that night because I did get
my data, and I stayed in the astronomy course
and dropped my history course, and, you know,
there was no going back from there.
I discovered that what I like to do is use
equipment and the bigger the better.
I love to be looking into space and being
the first person to see something.
It's like being an explorer, but not having
to leave the surface of the earth or travel
across an ocean.
And yet you know some of the things that you
see, you're the only person in the world who's
ever seen that.
It's a really exciting feeling to be an explorer
and to be able to bring that information back
and share with people.
I just love that thrill, that excitement,
to be right on the edge of something.